saint paul nommé premier ministre il y a
deux heures raymond barre succède à
jacques chirac
dans quelques instants en direct le
président de la république m haies
messieurs bonsoir
18h05 cet après midi monsieur raymond
barre est nommé premier ministre le
second premier ministre du septennat de
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
11h41 ce matin surtout les
téléscripteurs de toutes les rédactions
le suspense politique des derniers jours
prenait fin avec le flash suivant lesieu
jacques chirac a démissionné entre
parenthèses officiel c'est à 17h40 que
monsieur raymond barre avait fait son
entrée à l'elysée cet après midi et bien
évidemment cette arrivée était déjà un
indice très important pour la solution
de l'énigme que les journalistes se
posait depuis la démission de monsieur
jacques chirac
ce matin peu après l'annnonce de
monsieur jean françois poncet et donc au
terme de son entretien avec le président
de la république
le nouveau premier ministre raymond
barre a fait une déclaration aux
journalistes
la voici l'objectif principal de la
politique du nouveau gouvernement sera
de combattre l'inflation et de maintenir
la stabilité de notre monnaie
cette action pour difficile qu'elle soit
est indispensable pour assurer à la
france
la liberté le progrès
l'indépendance cette action est
également nécessaire pour permettre à
notre pays de jouer en europe et dans le
monde le rôle qui lui revient
elle sera amenée avec détermination et
dans un esprit d'équité
je suis convaincu que les françaises et
les français sont capables par un effort
de solidarité de maîtriser les problèmes
auxquels ils ont à faire face dans un
monde difficile et troublée
quant à moi sous la haute autorité du
président de la république
j'exercerai la fonction de premier
ministre dans la plénitude de ses
attributions et je m'efforcerai de
porter la charge qui vient de mettre
confié dans le seul intérêt de la nation
messieurs mesdames et messieurs j'aurai
le plaisir de vous revoir
mais je tiens à vous dire immédiatement
que je serais un premier ministre
économe de ses propos à bientôt
votre tâche sera facilitée j'expliquerai
tout ce qui devra être expliquée
c'était donc en quelques